HOUSE IS EXPECTED TO VOTE ON THE
BILL NEXT WEEK.
I'M ROBERT GRAY AND NOW BACK TO
THE GREG GUTFELD SHOW.
GREG: FINALLY, A DEMOCRAT ADMITS
THAT TRUMP'S DIPLOMACY MIGHT BE
WORKING.
>> THE SUMMIT WAS MUCH MORE SHOW
THAN SUBSTANCE BUT THE TEXANS
CALL ALL CATTLE, NO HAT.
[LAUGHTER]
ALL CATTLE AND NO HAT.
TRUMP IS ALL SUBSTANCE -- HOW
NICE OF MR. SCHUMER.
[APPLAUSE]
OF COURSE, CHUCK GOT IT WRONG
AND HE MADE THE OPPOSITE BUT I
CAN'T BLAME HIM BECAUSE HE'S ALL
HERE PLUG AND NO CATTLE.
[LAUGHTER]
TRUMPS CRITICS ALWAYS PHONE TO
GIBBERISH IN THEIR NEW SMEAR NOW
IS IT'S A CULT.
>> IT HAS DEVOLVED INTO A CULT.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS
DEVOLVED INTO A TRUMP CULT.
>> THESE GUYS ARE IN A CULT AND
DRINK THE COOL EYED, I DON'T
KNOW.
>> IT'S BECOMING A CULT.
>> THAT IS HARD NEWS FOR THE
REPUBLICANS THAT YOU ARE IN A
CULT.
GREG: THEY ALL SOUND THE SAME AS
IF THEY ARE IN A CULT.
[LAUGHTER]
A PROFITABLE ONE.
THE MORE THEY BACK TRUMP THE
HIGHER IN THE RATINGS.
THE TRUMP BUMP IS PAIN FOR THEIR
BOTOX.
IT EXPOSES THE LIES THAT THERE
IS A PRESS CRACKDOWN UNDER TRUMP
INDUSTRY HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
VOCAL IN OPPOSITION IN THE
PREVIOUS EIGHT YEARS WITH THE
MEDIA UNDER OBAMA -- TALK ABOUT
A CULT.
THEY WERE OBAMA TOAST.
YOU CAN HATE TRUMP, LOVE TRUMP
AND I DON'T REALLY EVEN CARE BUT
TARGETING PEOPLE -- THEIR ALL
HAT AND NO CATTLE BUT THEY'RE
ALL HAT AND NO JACKASS.
TO BE FAIR, TYRUS, EVERYBODY
THANKS SOMEONE ELSE IS IN A
CULPRIT IF YOU DON'T LIKE THEM
OR LIKE THEIR BELIEFS YOU SAY
THEY ARE IN A CULT.
TYRUS: CULT IS THE NEW CODE WORD
FOR JACKASS.
OR I DON'T LIKE YOU.
IT'S THE NEW THING.
SAYING BUT DID TRY TO FIX IT AND
THAT IS -- HE DID NOT KNOW BUT
HIS ASSISTANT NEW AND HIS
ASSISTANT LET IT GO BUT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO HOLLER AT THE GUY
BECAUSE GET A GOOD LOOK -- YOU
COULD STICK YOUR HEAD UP A COWS
ASS -- WHERE IS THE GUY THAT
WROTE THIS?
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING IN
THEIR RUNNING OUT OF STUFF.
NOW THEY ARE POSSESSED OF THE
DEVIL.
AND YOU CAN'T ARGUE THAT.
GREG: IS A CALL THAT BAD, CAT
QUESTION.
KAT: NOT TO THE PEOPLE IN IT.
I DO SEEM LIKE I WOULD BE THE
TYPE BUT -- I HAVE MANAGED TO
STEER CLEAR OF -- IT WOULD NOT
FEEL GOOD TO BELONG, YOU KNOW,
BUT I HAVE NOT GONE THAT FAR
YET.
IT'S ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE SOMEONE
TRY TO INSULT SOMEONE AND THEY
DO IT WRONG.
GREG: IT'S FANTASTIC.
KAT: IT'S LIKE IF YOU TRY TO
PUNCH SOMEONE IN THE FACE ANY
MISS AND YOU HIT THE WALL AND
YOU BREAK YOUR HAND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT HE DID THERE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND -- I GET HE
WAS TRYING TO BE RELATABLE BUT
THE INTERNET MAKES IT SUPER EASY
TO BE RELATABLE.
IF YOU ARE NOT SURE YOU GOOGLE
IT.
THERE IS NO WAY IT'S NOT LIKE WE
RELY ON ORAL HISTORIES TO KNOW
WHAT PEOPLE IN THE OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY ARE DOING.
YOU CAN GOOGLE IT.
IT'S SO EASY.
GREG: HE PROBABLY CALLS IT THE
GOOGLE.
[LAUGHTER]
WHERE IS THE GOOGLE?
I LEFT IT SOMEWHERE ON MY PHONE.
WALTER, THE GOOGLE.
>> THEY DON'T HIRE WRITERS AND
THAT'S THE BIG PROBLEM WITH
HOLLYWOOD POLITICS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> I THINK ANY POLITICIAN THAT
HAS A POPULIST FIELD WHETHER
TRUMP OR OBAMA OR WHOEVER IT IS
SARAH PALIN, FOR EXAMPLE, ALL
THESE PEOPLE HAVE THAT POPULIST
FEEL AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS YOU
DO HAVE A SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION THAT CAN FEEL A
LITTLE CULTISH.
THEY FOLLOW YOU NO MATTER WHAT
AND LOOK UP TO YOU AND BECOME A
PERSONALITY RATHER THAN A
POLITICIAN OR SOME, NATION.
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE ALSO TAKE A
TON OF HEAT.
TRUMP TAKES HEAT FROM THE MEDIA
EVERY DAY.
SARAH PALIN, SAME THING.
YEAH, THERE IS A CULTISH SEGMENT
OF THE POPULATION BUT SO WHAT?
TO SAY THAT TRUMP HAS CULTISH
FOLLOWERS AND OBAMA DID NOT,
EVERY PERSON ON THAT PANEL WAS
CULTISH FOR OBAMA.
COME ON QUESTION IS.
TYRUS: WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE DOING
THAT -- WAS THERE A BUNCH OF
TRUMP GUYS WITH RED TIES RUNNING
AROUND THE NORTH KOREAN SUMMIT?
WHAT IS THE CULT DOING OTHER
THAN THE PRESIDENT IS DOING HIS
JOB BUT I DON'T SEE --
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
GREG: ARE YOU SAYING -- IF I